wenn man jetzt das über die gesamte an
die mietzeit sieht dann glaube ich auch
wir uns am war auch keine optimale
lösung die wir gefunden haben aber doch
eine die von der klaren haltung geprägt
war es auf die präsenzunterricht wie
möglich wir sind davon schafft sind
dafür scharf kritisiert worden
übrigens auch von mir kolleginnen und
kollegen von frau finden bei uns im land
für diese haltung wir haben sie dann
trotzdem weiter durchgeführt und den
kanzler ich glaube das war auch richtig
das zu machen insofern wir bemühen uns
seit beginn der pandemie eine gute
abwägung zwischen recht auf bildung und
gesundheitsschutz zu treffen
wir haben die interessen und
jugendlichen im blick und deshalb glaube
ich brauche mir jedenfalls in bremen an
unserer grundhaltung grundkurs nichts
ändern